اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره قالت مصادر تركيه
للجزيره ان وزراء الدفاعي روسيا وسوريا
وتركيا اتفقوا على تشكيل لجان مشتركه من
مسؤوليه الدفاع والاستخبارات ستبدا
اجتماعتها نهايه الشهر المقبل في موسكو
تعقبها اجتماعات في انقره ودمشق واضافه
المصادر ان الوزراء في اجتماع موسكو
اتفقوا ايضا على اليه لتسهيل عوده
اللاجئين السوريين
وناقشوا تصورا يضعوا حدا لوجود ما تعرف
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه الشماليه سوري
سوريا
الكنيستا ثقه لتشكيله رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو الجديده باغلبيه 63 عضوا
وتتصدر اجنه الحكومه الجديده الاكثر
اليمنيه منذ انشاء اسرائيل تعزيز
الاستيطاني بالضفه الغربيه والجولان
وتسجيل السيطره على القدس المحتله
اعتبر الامين العام لحل في شمال الاطلسيه
اوكرانيا الاخيره على اهداف عسكريه في
روسيا اعتبرها مشروعه تماما واقل الصوت
البرج في تصريحاتنا وردتها وكاله الانباء
الالمانيه لان الدعم العسكريه لاوكرانيا
هو اسرع طريقه لتحقيق السلام كما اشهر
الصوت درج الى انه يمكن ان يكون هناك حل
سلما تفاوضي يضمن سيادته اوكرانيا
دوت انفجارات وانا عديده وسط العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف وقالت السلطات وان ضربات
صاروخيه روسيه كثيفه طالت المنشات الحيويه
في مناطق واسعه من البلاد وان العاصمه كيف
ومدينه اوديسا هما الاكثر تضررا
اعلنا حاكموا مقاطعه سرى طابا الروسيه
نادفاعات الجويه الروسيه اسقطت طائره
مسيره في منطقه انجلز حيث تقع قاعده جويه
روسيه في اثناء قالت بيلاروسيا اين
دفاعتها الجويه اسقطت صاروخا اوكرانيا
داخل اراضيها واستدعت منك السفيره
الاوكرانيه لديها للاحتجاج على سقوط
الصاروخ
رفض الامين العام للاتحاد التونسي للشغل
ما وصفها بسياسه المراوغه التي يعتمدها
رئيس الجمهوريه وقال ان عليه تحمل
مسؤولياته مؤكدا ان اتحاد الشغل لن يسمح
للرئيس ومعارضيه بالتلاعب بالبلاد على حد
قوله
وكان رئيس التونسي قيس سعيد قد اتهم من
وصفهم بالغارقين في الفساد بالسعي الى ضرب
امن الدوله
غيب الموت والاسطوره البرازيليه عن عمر
انها ذا 82 عاما بعد صراع طويل مع مرض
السرطان وقد اعلنت الحكومه والحداده ثلاثه
ايام عقبه اعلاني رحيله ويعتبروا بليه
اللاعب الوحيد الذي توج بلقب كاس العالم
ثلاث مرات وانا عدد من نجوم الكره
الاسطوره البرازيلي
اشكركم على متابعه الموجز انا ما كنتم
صامت اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]